like it's a dream to win a championship
but it's a dream to have the ball in
your hands
when the buzzer goes off i knew i was
keeping it like i was going to throw it
like sometimes you see like people like
throw it you see kobe do that everybody
i'm like no i'm keeping this i don't
care what happens
so who we got in the pool hall today we
got coach carol
what's up dmv smartest hey living good
great
you're one of the nicest players in the
dmv but how nice you're in the pool
table uh i'm i'm
okay yeah these work and these work
let's see what you can do let's see what
you can do on the break
there we go you spent the majority of
your time
in the wnba with sacramento marks but
you're drafted by the shock
yeah what happened on draft night well i
get drafted and
it's exciting obviously my mom my dad
excited
about getting drafted bill lambert was
the coach of the shock at the time i get
on the phone and that bear's like
yeah we're about we're going to trade
you
like he just said like congrats or like
or like anything you know he's just like
yeah we're working on trade so
you're not going to be here with us i'm
like welcome to the league
what do you remember day one when you
got to sacramento what do you recall
from that moment
i'd never been to sacramento so day one
i remember getting picked up at the
airport
and people that have been in the league
nba wnba
like there was nothing in sacramento
like now it's different
some people still might say there's
nothing in sacramento but i love
sacramento but
then it was like fields and like arko in
the middle of
nothing i was like where am i
i grew up in dmv went to school at
tennessee that was just an adjustment
being out on your own for the first time
now
hey strong shot that 2005 run what was
your favorite game that you recall from
that moment
probably the close out game probably
game four how was arco that game marco
was crazy
it was so loud you know they had never
won a championship in the city before
that was our last chance to do it there
because we didn't have home court in
that series
we played one and two on the road we
played three and four at home so to
close it out
there at home in front of our fans was
amazing
[Music]
what point four seconds left quick
inbound to you
yeah clyde goes triple zero yeah how are
you feeling
i was feeling great like it's a dream to
win a championship but it's a dream to
have the ball in your hands
when the buzzer goes off and so i knew i
was keeping it
any picture you find to me that night i
got the ball in my hand because i didn't
want anybody
to to take it and then i had everybody
on team sign it and i still have that
ball so you guys win the championship in
2005 and then
you're the first pro women's team on a
wheaties box
what does that mean you sell their box
too or no i still have the case at my
mom's house
the cereal's gone
for 15 years but um to stop the boxes
yeah
i was really cool growing up being on a
wheaties box was like i mean that was it
yeah so your final year
in sacramento was in 2009 but it wasn't
your choice the team folded
what was that season like for you we did
not know that that was coming
it was actually after the season i got a
call from
one of our front office people so i was
at my old
college visiting coach summit just got a
phone call and they said that we're done
and i was just in disbelief not even
emotional
just shocked and so you kind of lose a
generation of
players fans and young people that could
be inspired by
you know women playing the game so that
was hard it was hard to
transfer but you have to do it quick
that is the nature of pro sports
you can get traded so i just had to
focus on what was next but
i still miss it i still miss it out
there we're talking wba expansion
the viewership's up with 30 already so
far a lot more people are investing in
wnba
what do you think the future's like
right now for women's basketball the
athlete that you get now
is as focused as disciplined as driven
as before
they have unbelievable skill sets and
size like what some of the six five
players are able to do now
is completely different than when i was
in the league so what's different the
six five players now can do everything
or are allowed to do everything
i don't want to knock on the 65 players
back then but they weren't allowed to do
what they're allowed to do now they're
mostly posts post people
grabbing boards yeah things like that
and now they do everything
john paul jones is a beast she does
everything she shoots like 45
from three at six six like that's
amazing
you know stuart and what she's able to
do there's just
the length and the athleticism and the
skill level
is really impressive
[Music]
so carol let's see what you can do here
in the pop-up shot all right we're gonna
have 60 seconds
i'm gonna ask you some questions as
you're doing this same thing you can
make all right all right let's get it
the one athlete that are allowed to be
one of me
wayne gretzky best city to visit on the
road dc
home pregame snack meal routine what's
your favorite pre-game snack as a coach
not
i don't eat a lot
probably like some chicken and rice who
you listening to right now
j cole three on three or five on five
right now
in tokyo three on three funniest
teammate you ever had
uh probably a tie between kaleena green
and monique curry
gold medal or wnba championship oh
probably gold medal dirtiest opponent
you face at least the last week is
pretty dirty
best code you ever had that's something
[Music]
appreciate you for coming to the pool
hall best of luck to you in the olympics
and best of luck to do with the season
all right let's go